there are two main ways to handle combat
in Just Cause 3 the insane shooting
stuff till it goes boom way and the
tethering is much crap to other crap
until it goes boom way both ways will
produce some of the most satisfying
physics based explosions
in gaming
when you pick up Just Cause 3
initially everything will feel very
familiar and you'll find yourself
paragliding across the landscape blowing
up gas stations or attaching yourself to
explosive cylinders and flying several
hundred feet into the air but very
quickly you'll begin to realize that
Rico's toolset has expanded and the
skill ceiling has been raised
significantly with improvements made to
movement and grappling for starters Just
Cause 3 now lets the parachute do most
of the close-range combat flying at
which it excels the new wingsuit is
designed to handle the lion's share of
get in places real quick at high speed
managing the two together is what takes
a lot of practice and allows players to
be able to say grapple a tower and fire
rocket into it while launching yourself
into a back flip before zipping across
the map to dropkick a tower guard the
next part of the equation is the much
improved grappling hook it can be
upgraded to fire up to six tethers and
all of those tethers can be reeled in
the result is the immense freedom to
drag objects from one place to another
in order to set up very elaborate
shenanigans I got sidetracked multiple
times during my play session simply
attaching things to other things Air and
Space Museum did it attach a deer to an
airplane got that slingshot a man
between two buildings see you derail the
train
drag the statue head into traffic okay
at the point more than that though a
skilled player with multiple tethers can
get into a base and take it down using
grappling lines alone before the enemy
can even go on alert the grappling hook
is much more of a weapon than it wasn't
just cause - the other thing that I
enjoyed during my play session was a
greater variety of gear in the rebel
drops which let you parachute in items
you've earned or collected by dropping
off vehicles at friendly bases when
called in rebel drops fall from confetti
filled crates and spew Jets cars guns
and even boats
one issue I had with Just Cause 2 was
occasionally getting stuck out in the
middle of the ocean looking for
collectibles several of the helicopters
and planes now have pontoons so problem
solved the mini-map is gone by the way
so that players can focus on combat and
treasure hunting will be handled by
audio cues probably the one thing I'm
still not sure about from the play
session ahead I can tell that the joy of
Just Cause 3 sandbox is as strong as
it's ever been the new wingsuit and
multiple tethers means even more time
spent causing mayhem and
sidetrack for missions players you love
Just Cause two will find this game both
very familiar and much improve if that
sounds like you well then stay tuned to
game spot comm for ongoing coverage of
Just Cause 3 rising it back to the
response team at your position
the sport as Eddie